well let's let's talk about what the
government promises we have this story
from cbs how one lawmaker wants to curb
gun sales a 1 000 tax on semi-automatic
weapons before we read the news i'd like
to give a shout out to our good friend
michael malus with this quote all i'm
asking for is the right to the same
weapons that i paid for the taliban to
own yeah bravo good sir i completely
agree well this is the ukrainians and
the and the mexican cartels and let's
let's forget all the you know uh
dictatorships in latin america that we
financed and we funneled money through
through iran contra i could keep going
by the way we do a skit where it's like
a guy talking to obama and he's like mr
president did you give a bunch of those
a bunch of these high-powered rifles two
cartels yes i did uh can i have one no
you can't yep that's it yep
very quick oh very good that's a very
good oh well but but again the us
government literally is one of the chief
exporters of weaponry in the world but
but also not for us though but yeah yeah
but but not just not just the afghanis
let's not forget isis uh radical
jihadists inside of syria that literally
had the latest u.s uh uh you know
technology uh gear weapons yeah from
detroit whatever toyota trucks uh that
were given to them radical islamists
were were armed to the teeth uh yeah
muhajin in the 1880s let's talk about
this new story cbs says one house
democrat is a novel idea for curbing the
sale of automatic weapons like ar-15s
blah blah blah the proposed bill places
a 1 000 excise tax on any type of
semi-automatic firearm pushing up the
price of the military-style weapon
beyond the means of many potential
buyers fake news cbs i just want to
shout out when these journalists write
garbage nonsense military style hunting
rifles are identical it's just it's
ridiculous nonsense but i just want to
mention
right away
if you increase the cost of these
weapons by a thousand percent crime will
get worse yeah because all of a sudden
your 500 hand gun is a 5 500 handgun and
boy can people make money off that also
it mentions many potential buyers we
priced out well that's a convenient way
of saying that these rich political
leaders who are proposing these kinds of
things will still have armed securities
who work for armed security
organizations that can afford this kind
of thing they'll be able to purchase
these weapons to protect their families
you will not be able to
what they're saying is because it's a
revenue measure it can bypass the
filibuster and get past the simple
majority yeah they think they can do it
via reconciliation i will say kudos to
them i'm shocked they hadn't thought of
this earlier it's actually kind of
ingenious because they're not actually
preventing you from buying any sort of
they're not they're not taking your
rights away for weapons but they're
making it more expensive they did this
already with the nfa so this is just
them saying let's let's apply
to standard semi-automatic weapons the
same rules that apply to select fire
rifles well you talked about this a
couple episodes ago with the 72-hour
waiting period for background checks if
you just get rid of that and you extend
it you can prevent people from owning a
firearm just by saying that so this is a
very it's a little ingenious i'm
surprised they didn't do it that doesn't
mean i think it's a good idea but you
know i thought about when it comes to
just gun control and all that stuff and
what democrats would do i've said two
things on twitter i don't want to hear
democrats talk about gun control in
seattle at least in washington state
until they do two things acknowledge
that it was wrong for uh
riders up at chop to hand stolen rifles
out of the back of a trunk of a car
which they never condemned and then two
until they stopped cutting deals with
people who commit gun crimes in
washington state there's so many people
who commit crimes actual criminals
commit crimes with a gun who then get a
sweetheart deal um you know some plea
deal with prosecutors and then you know
politicians turn around and say that
they want gun control the only thing i
have an issue with in that story about
chop was the stolen part i think people
have a right to keep and bear arms if
someone if they had legal weapons and
they were handing them out i don't see
an issue i i think there there are
issues with
you know political extremists who are
armed and killing kids like they did in
chop but i think
i think we have a problem with the over
regulation of weapons as
a as a pathetic attempt to stop people
from getting them which it clearly
doesn't what i'm saying is if
you've got this guy rasimo and the
warlord of chop who's opening up the
trunk of a car handing out rifles to
people who didn't look 21 to me and you
don't have politicians in the city of
seattle condemn that yet at the same
time they're pro-gun control that that's
ridiculous we we make i make i make this
point all the time but luke just made it
earlier that the m1a is banned in
maryland but not the scar 20s for those
that are from like they're basically the
same caliber weapon but one is like an
older one's a newer it's just peop
actually let me put it this way the
people who know nothing about guns
trying to regulate them is their
achilles heel
36 states have permit less open carry 25
of constitutional carry florida is set
to be the 26th and all of that expanse
of gun access is happening because the
people arguing against it are like we
got to ban the air 15 and you're like
it's meaningless it's not going to
happen fine whatever as they're arguing
for more weapons for ukraine by the way
yeah
exactly no no so i just want to make
this point they don't know much about
guns but they know one incredibly
important instrumental thing which is
that guns allow you to protect yourself
that is why we see this constant cycle
all right this this has begun
probably two three years ago and expect
to see it continue to repeat they riot
they say it's okay for them to burn down
your city and threaten your life rides
cool down we need to take your guns when
you take your guns then they ride again
or they threaten to ride again then as
soon as that calms down they need to
take your guns right just a couple weeks
ago they were they were threatening
insurrection over the supreme court
potentially overturning roe and then
they're going to ask you why do you need
an ar-15 well because the dominant media
culture and virtually every political
leader in this country who aligns
themselves with the status quo isn't
trying to get themselves in trouble all
the big tech companies sanction your
violence against me so yes i do want to
be able to protect myself and my family
before the show started i actually
posted a meme of fidel castro and
there's there's the question what can
you do with a population after you
disarm them and then castro's laughing
down there anything i want and that's
the story of history that's the story
that has happened throughout all of
written recorded history that we need to
understand here i think it's important
for people to be able to defend
themselves because who are you going to
rely on the yuvali police department to
be there for you during critical moments
and times no they're going to arrest you
handcuff you if if your child's getting
shot
oh no no no no no no no your ability to
defend yourself is absolutely crucial
and important and it terrifies people
that you could defend yourself that you
could stand up for yourself and this is
why they're putting out all the stops
trying to take away that ability from
from you and so i want to make two
points about that so what we saw at
uvalde is basically what gun control
advocates push for without realizing it
they want to put you in a position where
the police spend their time and energy
disarming you and preventing you from
protecting your loved ones while maniacs
still run around committing heinous
crimes and that's exactly what's going
to happen if there's more gun control
just like there is actually what happens
exactly that is what gun control does
and also they constantly point to
countries like australia and they'll
claim look the gun ban in australia
worked well not really gun crime was
plummeting at an identical rate before
the gun ban but this is even more
important but hold on but now do
venezuela now do mexico exactly also
also as soon as the australian gun ban
occurred they said look australia isn't
a tyrannical nation as if our argument
is it would happen overnight but then
after a couple years look under the
covert regime australia has literal
concentration camps they are
concentrating if you are placed in a
holding facility without a trial without
due process without due process and you
are forced to stay there that is in a
camp that is a concentration camp they
literally have those in australia after
banning guns because you can't do that
to an armed population the definition of
a concentration camp i believe from the
holocaust museum was
a place where uh a
concentration camp was a place where
people were held without due process
without charge or trial so when the
government comes and takes people and
puts them in a secure facility where
they're not allowed to leave that was
the the base definition so there were
indigenous people in australia who were
rounded up
under covet suspicion and sent there and
they were trying to escape climbing
fences i want to pull up a couple images
for you guys so that you can uh because
i i'm going to assume a lot of people
don't know a lot about guns and i'm not
going to pretend to be a gun expert here
but take a look at this image right here
this is
the uh this this looks like a hunting
rifle that's that's the way that it's
often described by people on the left
they say they say oh you know take a
look at this it's a hunting rifle that's
what you should have let me show you
this image right here ooh that's a scary
assault weapon look at that it's got the
pistol grip and that scope on it oh man
oh geez yeah the first one is the m1
garand literally used in war the second
one is a 450 bushmaster hunting rifle
they have no idea what they're talking
about again i'm not going to pretend to
be an expert on this one i can just
point out right away that they have no
idea they're talking about here's the
best part someone in the super chat said
hey tim pull up a ruger mini 14.
functionally the same as an ar-15 but
they don't want to ban that one oh i'm
sorry that's a hunting rifle you know
why it's got a wood a wood stock with
the rifle grip these people have no idea
what they're talking about but you know
what as i sit back and they regulate
things that make no sense i'm like okay
whatever dude
i want to point something out to you
guys
when when i saw this meme and they were
like
oh this is a it showed a picture of what
looked like a bunch of m1s and it was
like these are weapons made for hunting
and then it showed a bunch of pistol
grip you know rifles that these are made
for killing people
and they were talking about gun control
and saying see this is why we should get
rid of these i'm like
do you think that bullets intended for
humans work on big game or deer
do you think that a deer is a larger
creature than a human okay so it stands
to reason that
typically you will want something more
powerful for hunting right as opposed to
combat
i i love it when i'm talking to people
and i'll show them you know like the
ammo we have when we go to the range or
whatever and they'll see a nine
millimeter round or a polymer tip 450
bushmaster and i'm like which one's the
weapon of war
and then people don't know how i'm
trying to trick them so they typically
will be like uh it's gonna be the little
one isn't it because i'm like yes
because the big one is for killing deer
which are bigger than people so when
they talk about you should only have
things for hunting oh okay great now
we're gonna some lunatic was going to go
out with with slugs 41 mini slugs in a
ksg25 these people have lost their minds
well they never had them in the first
place this stuff roused me up and i'm
not even a gun expert mind you i'm sure
you guys in the chat can correct me a
lot of this stuff and talk about how
it's even worse than i'm saying biden
says you just need a shotgun right
nine millimeter
long out of someone i went we went to
the gun shop the other day and they had
they had you didn't invite me i'm a fan
you weren't here
and i was getting a 12 gauge and they
have they have a 12 gauge with a
rotating magazine tube it has four
magazine tubes i think it holds 25. and
the guy at the shop is like oh this one
you're gonna your shoulder is going to
be hurting after this one man and i'm
like yeah i know but you know it looks
cool so i want to get it and then i'm
like isn't it funny that joe biden is
telling people to get shotguns which are
harder to use
they have no idea they're talking like i
i i i'm i'm
reluctant to talk about what would what
would actually happen if some of these
crazies decided to use hunting weapons
these people are so dumb they keep
regulating things that make guns more
dangerous
you know exactly they go off but you
know you don't need uh you don't need x
amount of rounds not you don't need an
air 15 how do you know have you ever
hunted in your life you've ever spoken
dude basically i don't know a single
person who hunts and is in favor of gun
control i'm sure there's some somewhere
well they're called unbelievably rare
yeah well also
in washington state they banned uh high
capacity magazines which they set at 10
rounds
which for anybody who knows guns isn't
really high capacity it's it's low
capacity when you buy a weapon it comes
with a 30 an air 15 will come with a 30
round mag for five ten rounds is not
high capacity but you know there's an
argument i have a friend who survived
the vegas shooting so um and i just had
her on my podcast the other day and you
know we had a nice conversation about
where she's at and what she went through
and i can't even imagine or put myself
there and she was one of the people who
got through this 10 round high capacity
magazine and one of the points she
brings up is well if you're you know
people say you need to defend yourself
in your home you don't need you
shouldn't need 10 bullets it's like i
probably wouldn't need 10 bucks it's
like i can't hit anything and it's like
i don't want to i don't want to risk
needing 11 or 12 bullets i mean i'm not
a gun person i don't own any guns but we
have you know guns in our home but and
there's there's so many unanswered
questions about that vegas incident that
again was brought up initially it was
one of the largest mass shootings and
then the corporate media just dropped it
stopped talking about it didn't even
care afterwards it's absolutely daunting
same thing with with kenosha yeah
they're like not a terror attack
everybody move on yep it doesn't matter
it doesn't fit the narrative doesn't fit
the agenda we can't emotionally
manipulate people to get what we want
out of this so we're just gonna drop it
and not talk about it that's essentially
what happened here i remember also
seeing a meme earlier
showing ms-13 gangbangers talking to
each other and one of them's like hey
are we going to the drive-by shooting
today and then the other ms-13
gangbanger looks at the other guy says i
can't i didn't get my gun permit today i
can't do that so this is this is how
people think the laws are going to work
here they're going to be affecting the
the the people who don't respect the law
in the first place no it's going to
affect law-abiding citizens anybody
who's paying attention knows this is
just about disarming the population it
has nothing to do with preventing any of
these these these shootings or crime or
anything like that and you know it's
crazy because now they're coming out and
they're like 10 mass shootings over the
weekend and i was like oh now you care
about chicago yeah please dude exactly
chicago the gun free zone the place with
so much restrictions on people's ability
to defend themselves where criminals
know that there's going to be people
there who can't do anything if you put a
gun in their face because they can't
defend themselves when they attack them
so then you watch these videos out of
brazil man and it's crazy yeah where
like there's that viral video where the
the guy walks up to the group of women
and he's got a gun and he's like shaking
at him and this woman just pulls out a
gun and shoots him and he just hits the
deck
i watched uh man i watched these on
another video where these three guys
break into a house
and you can see the guy like sleeping in
his bed watching youtube or something
like he fell asleep watching youtube
videos and then all of a sudden you see
this woman just walk up with a revolver
bang bang and the dudes jump out the
window yeah i mean what better way to to
be able to protect yourself than than be
able to have a firearm what you're going
to do by taking firearms away from
individuals is making them potential
future victims i think i just want to
make one more point what's ironic is
these people who will argue that our
brains have just been
completely um you know rotted away at by
gun culture and all the action movies
basically have all the opinions they
have about guns
based on action films like they really
think you just point at the person pull
the trigger you're gonna hit them every
single time and so that's why they ask
questions like why would you need 10
rounds or more look if someone breaks
into your home your adrenaline's gonna
be in the dark in the dark it's gonna
like you're gonna be shaking even if
you're well trained it's gonna be a
difficult situation so to sit there go
why would someone need more than 10
rounds i i think uh what is it like
police officers only hit their target
something like 30 of the time and high
stress situations and they train more
regularly than your average citizen how
many conversations have you at home had
where someone was like why didn't they
shoot the gun out of the perpetrator's
hand yes
this is my favorite this is my favorite
why didn't they just shoot him in the
leg
what what and hit a major artery hey i
write and kill him that's why i love
when they make the mainstream reporters
go do the assignment where they take the
the training and they have somebody like
shoot him with a fake gun it's like oh
you're dead because you didn't act fast
enough when i was uh beginning my career
in seattle i covered crime and justice
before i switched over to politics and i
made a point before i talked about any
use of force i would have that use of
force done i mean short of being shot
like when um eric garner wasn't killed
by new york police in a in a chokehold
so i let some police officer on camera
choke me in an lvnr a lateral vascular
neck restraint choke me unconscious
to see what it would be like and i gotta
say i would rather that happen than uh
pepper spray or anything like that
because that's much worse than being
choked out but i think it would be good
for reporters it should be kind of
standard in newsrooms to make them go
through
some of that training that police go
through before they talk about it you
know things like that like shooting and
i think well i think there are plenty
police officers who would volunteer to
choke a reporter that's what i was going
to say is i'm sure that we could
celebrate program city of lakewood
police department they asked me for that
video i don't know where the video went
but uh city of lakewood they jumped at
the opportunity to do that they could
stream this on youtube super chat thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm we'll see
you all there